[Musique]
oui bon c'est ça alors à tout de suite
hein je vous attendais sinon c'est une
surprise a tout de suite
un bon jour devinez sur quoi je me
balance
élégamment
eh bien oui c'est un véritable rappel de
cirque un cadeau deux mois du snob à
tous les habitants de l'île alors comme
françois et julie vont pas tarder à
arriver je leur donne rendez-vous ici eh
bien je vais me cacher dans le kiosque
pour regarder leur réaction
alors surtout ne vous dit rien a tout de
suite
qu'est ce que tu crois que plus bien
vouloir cette grande fille celle de
monsieur du snob et casimir pour la 15e
fois de traite pas monsieur du snop de
grande fille soeur bras excuse moi
j'aurais dû dire grand spaghetti
filiforme a pas davantage casimir bon
alors un grand tirage maigrichonne
peut-être encore moins bon ben ça va
j'ai compris j'ai compris ce charmante
amy kate moss yeux du snap et ben voilà
c'est beaucoup mieux comme ça et j'en
sais absolument rien au téléphone il
avait un air très mystérieux il n'a rien
voulu me dire plus rien en france on
regarde qu'est ce que c'est que ce
morceau de bois accroché après de
ficelle à salomé c'est un trapèze qui
peut l'avoir accroché la pop c'est
sûrement ce être grande en double dames
je veux dire à ceux charmante amis de
monsieur lucien et c'est sûrement ça
doit être la surprise dont il me parlait
au téléphone
et alors attrapé ça sert à à s'opposer
le nom quasi me rattraper ça sert à
faire de la gymnastique et dans les
cirques ça sert même à faire de
l'acrobatie
l'étude s'est joué à l'acrobate toi non
non non mais chez faire quelques petites
choses qui regardent le cochon pendu
regarde bien
ces cochons tendu ça bon alors
comme ça tu rassembles à un cochon très
bien ça si tu faisais mais bien la
ressemblance serait parfait état
c'est très amusant que les émirs caisse
énergie j'ai la tête qui tourne
oh ça va pas
non mais alors que c'est de ma faute je
manquais d'entraînement quand on fait un
effort violent d'abord il faut c'est
chauffer les muscles
d'accord moi je veux bien faire un peu
d'exercice avec toi et après je monterai
sur le trapèze il montera sur le trapèze
bon si tu veux alors c'est comme ça la
2 3 4 allée d'accord
2 3 4 1 2 3 plaques ses formidables
parce qu'en plus on apprend à conthey
savoir me dabo maintenant casimir un peu
de footing on va jusqu'au petit vois
aller retour aller derrière moi alors
[Rires]
rien de tel pour vous ouvrir l'appétit
le trait gras ne prennent pas plus vite
approchez approchez
rené voir la grande exposition
scientifique du nouveau du jamais vu lui
n'est dû ni rien dans cette exposition
de très nouveau
explication de la germination
et le principe du téléphone ça n'a rien
d'inédit
je dis ça car tu n'as pas encore vu mon
stand bien je vais te présenter une
invention personnelle qui va
révolutionner le monde c'est un nouveau
ballon etc at il de particulier ce
ballon
regarde c'est un ballon cubique
et je suis l'inventeur du ballon cubique
l on l avantage tu veux dire les
avantages eh bien d'abord une facilité
de rangement vois tu je peux mettre 27
ballons cubique dans ma boîte en carton
alors que si j'avais des des ballons
ronds ordinaire j'en mettrais tout au
plus 10 ou 12 ans
ensuite il ne glisse pas lorsque l'on
pose
dessus donc impossibilité de se casser
accidentellement une jambe
[Musique]
comment roule-t-il ton ballon
il y faut qu'il roule mon cher grouchy
le propre d'un ballon et de rouler pour
cela il faut qu'il soit rousse ferrique
comme une orange si tu préfères portant
ballon est un cube ses côtés sont des
carrés
il est donc
utilisable pour écoute totale j'ai
inventé un nouveau ballon fait déjà pas
si mal si en plus il faut qu'il roulait
bien toi demande beaucoup trop
c'est vrai quoi faut quand même pas être
trop exigeant
[Musique]
des trapèzes j'adore ça
bien tabouret pour monter dessus c'est
grand luxe
mais
voilà c'est merveilleux de voir l'île
d'ô comme ça
et puis ça fait du vent
mon dieu j'ai fait tomber le tabouret
comment je vais redescendre
j'ai unités au secours et des
moissons détient pas très loin voilà
merci
ça là surprise
on ne peut rien vous cacher ma chère
amie c'est un cadeau de philbert en
selle du sommet c'est-à-dire mois aux
habitants de nos enfants véritable
trapel de cirque trapèze de supprimer
alors qui va s'en servir mais enfin
chers amis regarder devant vous vous
allez voir un véritable acrobate
professionnels
une fois personne enfin rendez-vous bien
si voyons chers amis
l'acrobate professionnel c'est moi
d'abord parce qu'il
faut écouter monsieur 19 je voudrais pas
vous vexer m'enfin un acrobate de cirque
que c'est quelqu'un qui m'était très
musclé sans vouloir vexer en fait
beaucoup de peine en sous-estimant mes
capacités musculaires le bouger pas dit
si je veux mettre en tenue d'acrobates
et je reviens
bien moi en attendant je vais demander à
françois qu'il apporte sa trousse de
secouriste un accident est vite arrivé
maintenant monsieur du snob ne devrait
plus tarder
j'espère que tu as pris ta trouve des
secouristes au monde je lève avant mais
j'espère bien ne pas avoir pensé à vous
et moi aussi
attention la voilà
au faux bond
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
lentement l'abandon de makram le cas le
feu
dimanche soir très gentil benoît
prestation de commencer les exercices
auxquels je vais me livrable avec grand
plaisir mais s'ils disent 'non' alors
monsieur du snap pour s'échauffer va
d'abord faire quelques groupes et
regardez bien il va ramener les genoux
sur la poitrine voilà
et maintenant quelques battements
la très très bon sur le travail des
abdominaux et quelques tractions
maintenant monsieur du snop regardez
bien
oui
voilà une position
une deuxième et peut-être une troisième
non voilà bravo au losc jusqu'en
mai peut regarder bien monsieur 10,9 à
faire une mise en jarez ses pieds ne
vont pas toucher la barre du trapèze au
passage regardez bien
il prend son élan et voilà
[Musique]
regard quasi maintenant monsieur 10,9 à
faire un temps cambrai
et nathan monsieur 10 nov montrez nous
comment on s'assied sur le trapèze
regarde casimir comment ça c'est sur un
trapèze est une technique et vous est
peut-être terminée monsieur du snob en
vous prenant les chevilles dans les
cordes on la regarde bien casimir car
après ce sera ton taux de faire une
démonstration
formidable et bien maintenant casimir à
toi mon vieux quel avenir
mais qui aligna c'est ça ton tour
[Applaudissements]